hi i'm marie and this is my recipe for
chocolate tart
one of my favorite dessert is a tart
they can seem really intimidating but i
wanted to show you how easy it was to
make make sure butter and egg is room
temperature because if you use room
temperature butter with cold eggs they
don't mix well together when you mix
butter and egg you can use hand mixer or
whisk but once you add flour you should
switch to spatula because you don't want
to create a lot of gluten because the
cookie dough will become tough and hard
if you over mix some baking recipes say
to leave the butter at room temperature
but they don't mention that eggs should
also be room temperature which is very
important in recipes like this one
you also want to rest the dough for 30
minutes so it relaxes the gluten and
also the dough is really soft so you
want to make the butter a little harder
and it's easier to roll it out if the
dough breaks when you're molding it it's
okay you can patch it with leftover
dough make sure to poke holes so that
the dough doesn't poof up if you make
something difficult to make and you make
it really well it can boost your
confidence so this toy is great for any
beginner cooks who wants to challenge
themselves a little bit also i use the
instant coffee in this recipe because it
kind of gives a nice bitterness and a
flavor that balances out with the
sweetness of the chocolate so that the
tart doesn't become overly sweet but if
you don't like coffee you can totally
skip this step and it will work just
fine it's just a flavor preference when
you're pouring wet ingredients into the
chocolate pour everything at once then
count 30 seconds and then start mixing
it makes really nice shiny chocolate
filling
also make sure to use good quality dark
chocolate because this recipe is very
simple so quality is very important so
when you bake it make sure to take the
tar out when the center part is slightly
jiggling because if you over cook it the
chocolate filling start cracking shake a
little bit and if the center slightly
jiggled that is when you have to take
out from the oven this recipe i learned
from a pastry chef i used to work with
at the restaurant in l.a so it's totally
restaurant quality dessert and you can
impress anyone who loves chocolate this
chocolate tart is silky and rich so you
will be satisfied just like tiny slice
this recipe seems a little bit
challenging but if you follow step by
step you can totally make it and you
will be impressed by yourself impress
yourself first and impress other people
next
and it's totally worth that
thank you
i cannot be alex
thank you for watching oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you